ariel y otros asentamientos cercanos
fueron cerrados a primera hora del
sábado después de que dos hombres
armados dispararan y mataron a un
guardia de seguridad y el carné de un
vehículo con matrícula de amarillas
llegó al lugar dos terroristas estaban
dentro del coche y empezaron a disparar
cuyo goo goo de las fuerzas de seguridad
israelíes han realizado detenciones y
han incautado armas en una localidad
cercana mientras el grupo militante
palestino vinculado al fatah la brigada
de los mártires de al-aqsa reivindicaba
la autoría del atentado es el último en
un fuerte aumento de la violencia entre
israelíes y palestinos en las últimas
semanas en medio de un aumento de las
tensiones en torno al complejo de la
mezquita de al aqsa en jerusalén este el
tercer lugar más sagrado del islám se
encuentra en el monte del templo el
lugar más venerado del judaísmo israel
se anexionó jerusalén del este junto con
cisjordania tras la guerra de los seis
días de 1967 en una medida no reconocida
por la comunidad internacional además ha
impuesto restricciones que hacen
prácticamente imposible que la mayoría
de los palestinos recién en la mezquita
este mes se han producido múltiples
enfrentamientos en el recinto al
coincidir las celebraciones musulmana
del ramadán y la pascua judía dirigencia
queremos visitar la mezquita de al-aqsa
y rezar dentro porque hacerlo triplica
la recompensa
los ocupantes son responsables de la
agresión que está ocurriendo aquí
hace casi un año un desalojo de familias
palestinas de jerusalén éste provocó una
guerra de 11 días que terminó con un
acuerdo de alto el fuego entre israel y
hamás el grupo militante que gobierna
gaza los palestinos reclaman jerusalén
este como capital de su futuro estado
israel la llama a su capital eterna
desde 1949